-You guys, my guest tonigh
is John Legend.
[ Cheers and applause ]
John has won an Oscar, a Tony,
an Emmy, a Grammy,
and he was named
People Magazine's
Sexiest Man Alive.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Even more impressive --
his Uber passenger rating is 6
I mean, wow, that's --
He must give his driver a mint
Hey, I want to wish everyone
a happy Friday.
If you think you're relieved
that this week's over,
imagine how
the president feels.
What a week.
We had impeachment hearings.
We had a Democratic debate
Ariana Grande endorsed
Bernie Sanders.
And yet,
all anybody will remember
is that someone farted
on MSNBC.
[ Laughter ]
It was a brutal week
for President Trump.
Witness after witness
testified against him.
I don't want to say
it was a disaster,
but even Prince Andrew was like,
"How you holding up, buddy?"
[ Light laughter ]
Seriously, though, I'm not
saying Trump was in bad shape,
but even Don Jr. was like,
"You know what?
We're gonna do Thanksgivin
at Boston Market this year
We're good."
This week,
while addressing the media
there was a photo going around
of Trump's notepad,
and a lot of people were
commenting on his handwriting.
Take a look.
Have you seen this?
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-It's real.
Well, today, I read that
Donald Trump's handwriting -
and this is real --
is actually available as a
free font called "Tiny Hand.
Here it is, right there.
That's the font.
That's pretty crazy.
But they actually tried ou
a few other names for the font
before landing on Tiny Hand.
-Oh. Oh, boy.
Here we go.
-Tariq, what's up, dawg?
-Let me guess.
You're gonna
make fun of Trump
by listing off a bunch of
rejected font names, right
-I mean, yeah.
That was the plan.
-And then, each joke will
pop up as, like, a graphic
so everyone can see it,
and laugh about it.
-Right.
-I know exactly how
this'll go.
So, the top of the screen
is gonna say something like,
"Rejected Trump Font Names."
And then, underneath that,
it'll say things like,
"Sharpie Pro Quo,"
and "Bigly Squiggly,"
or "Failing New York Times
New Roman,"
and finally,
"Hillary-vetica."
[ Laughter ]
Is...
Is that how this
is gonna go?
-Yeah, pretty much.
You nailed it, Tariq.
-Yeah, you shouldn't
do that bit.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. I won't.
Tariq Trotter, everybody.
Thank you for telling me that.
I won't do it.
Hey, guys, we are one week awa
from Black Friday.
Ooh, wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is that yearly traditio
of people lining up
outside department stores
for hours,
and then realizing they ca
buy it all from home
on Cyber Monday.
[ Laughter ]
I read that Amazon wants t
ship customers anything
in 30 minutes.
-Wait. Wait.
Jimmy, hold up.
You're telling me that you could
order something on Amazon,
and get it in 30 minutes?
-That's the plan.
-Can you order anything?
-If it's on Amazon,
then, sure, I guess.
-Hmm. Very cool.
Hey, continue with
your monologue, man.
I'm loving it so far!
Laughs galore, baby.
Ha-ha, ha-ha, ha-ha.
[ Laughter ]
-Anyway,
this is interesting.
A tree frog in --
I'm sorry.
Sorry, who are you?
-Oh, I have a package
for Kamal Grey.
-Yeah.
Yes!
My favorite album,
right here!
It's my favorite!
It's my favorite,
right here!
-Oh, my gosh.
-Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
-James -- James' album.
-Can I get an autograph?
Can I get your autograph?
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, guys, I heard that
Victoria's Secret
has officially canceled
their fashion show --
or as one guys put it --
[ As Trump ] "Oh, my God,
this week can't get worse.
[ Laughter ]
"Say it ain't so."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Normal voice ] I saw that
the Property Brothers
are starting a magazine.
They plan on handling the
magazine just like their show --
one brother will create
the entire thing,
the other will do nothing
in a suit.
[ Light laughter ]
And finally, a new study found
that teenaged elephants
are like human teenagers -
they make a lot of mistakes,
they're stubborn,
and they take risks.
In response, teen elephant
sucked on a vape and said,
"You don't know me."